y
ah
[Música]
en plena segunda ola de la pandemia en
españa a pesar de que de momento la
situación no sea tan grave como durante
la primavera preocupa el aumento de los
contagios y sobre todo el de las
hospitalizaciones y particularmente aquí
en la comunidad de madrid' la región
europea con mayor incidencia acumulada y
también la región española que acumula
alrededor de un tercio de los casos ya
no solamente desde el inicio de la
pandemia sino también desde la semana
pasada por eso mismo aquí en la
comunidad de madrid' ya se han puesto en
marcha nuevas medidas para intentar
frenar la curva de contagios medidas
destinadas principalmente a reducir la
movilidad de los vecinos que viven en
los barrios y en los pueblos de la
región más tocados por la pandemia pero
tanto los vecinos de estas zonas como el
personal sanitario indican por un lado
de que son medidas que consideran poco
efectivas ya que la mayoría de estos
vecinos tienen que desplazarse cada día
a otros puntos de la capital para
trabajar pero sobre todo porque son
medidas que no vienen acompañadas del
conveniente refuerzo del sistema
sanitario sobre todo del sistema de
atención primaria que está desbordado lo
que implica una falta de seguimiento de
rastreo
y por supuesto de atención a las
personas enfermas
[Música]
en francia continúa el fuerte repunte de
casos de coronavirus en la última semana
se registraron hasta 13.000 casos en un
mismo día algo inédito el número de
hospitalizaciones y de ingresos en
reanimación también va en aumento ya son
varios los hospitales que están en
tensión sobre todo en el sur del país a
esto se suma la saturación de los
laboratorios que realizan las pruebas
moleculares hasta 1.200.000 por semana
pero con una entrega de resultados
tardía de 10 días cuando debería ser
máximo de 72 horas por eso el gobierno
ha pedido se le dé una prioridad a las
personas que tengan una orden médica a
quienes hayan estado en contacto con
algún positivo y también al personal
sanitario y de hecho aquí en parís en la
región de la capital se han desplegado
20 lugares más donde hacerse ese test
molecular a esto se suma que va a
comenzar a utilizarse también el test de
antígeno cuyo resultado se obtiene en
tan solo 30 minutos y que debería ser
generalizado a partir del mes de octubre
[Música]
los rusos están empezando a preocuparse
por el coronavirus de nuevo y con razón
porque los datos están dando nuevos
avisos rusia tenía el mes pasado 4.000
casos nuevos al día y ahora estamos en
6000 un dato preocupante aunque todavía
no tan malo como los 11 mil contagios
diarios del pasado mes de mayo es verdad
que cada vez se hacen más pruebas se
hacen más pruebas que antes aunque no
con la misma minuciosidad en todos los
rincones del país por eso es interesante
ir a lo que fue el epicentro de la
pandemia aquí en rusia a moscú donde
hemos estado durante el verano con 600
casos nuevos al día de una manera muy
estable y ahora en los últimos días ha
habido un repunte hasta los 900 aquí hay
miedo a un nuevo confinamiento y están
puestas todas las esperanzas en la
vacuna rusa que ya se está distribuyendo
pese a que todavía se están haciendo los
ensayos de la última fase de pruebas
[Música]